I was looking for the most
unreconstructed cooking I could find
cooking as it's been practiced for
thousands if not millions of years and I
found that in Eastern North Carolina
whole hog barbecue where there is no
sauce to speak of it's just this animal
slow-cooked over a fire wood fire and
the place where I first found it was a
barbecue joint in Ayden North Carolina
near the coast called the skylight Inn I
don't know why it's called the skylight
Inn there is no skylight and there is
also on top of this building a Capitol
dome like you see in Washington sitting
on top of this building that didn't make
any sense either except they told me
that National Geographic had said they
were the capitol of barbecue in 1965 and
they put up this dome in the skylight
the skylight Inn had a restaurant in
front where they're selling barbecue
sandwiches very few items on the menu
but basically barbecue sandwiches sweet
tea coleslaw you know that's basically
it and in the back were these two
structures buildings made of cinder
block with the metal roof and in there
in these buildings where it was the the
pit room the barbecue pit and when you
went in Sam Samuel Jones who was the
proprietor says welcome to the vestibule
of hell and I walk in and we opened the
door and we're just assaulted by the
smoke it's delicious smelling smoke and
inside is a giant fireplace with logs
like this I mean it looks like you know
a giant fireplace and the the grate is
made out of truck axles that's how big
it is and they're burning down wood to
coals and then they're shoveling the
coals in these long cinder block
containers that have a grate on top and
on top of the grate sit these whole pigs
these pink you know pigs with their
heads and tails intact splayed out and
they shovel the the the coals underneath
in an outline of the pig form and
there's a man
mr. Howell who is the pitmaster who says
very little and he's just kind of
wheeling back and forth to the walk-in
and he's got this wheelbarrow with a
piece of bloody plywood on top and he
goes back into the back room and he
comes back and there's a dead hog on it
and he wheels it over tips it onto the
grade shovels some coals beneath it and
the entire room is an oven basically a
low temperature oven you know and the
animals are cooked at around 200 degrees
for over 20 hours this house goes
overnight you can barely see in the room
and the pigs look oddly human I mean
they're pink there are sighs there they
have these little slice smiles it's a
really kind of upsetting tableau and
it's hard to imagine eating what's
coming out of this room but but come
back the next day and those pink
alarming carcasses are honey colored
they smell delicious and you develop an
appetite for them and so mr. Howell
carts them into the restaurant and
there's a giant chopping block and a man
stands behind the chopping block and
takes big hunks of this animal and
starts chopping it with two cleavers the
chopping block has been chopped so much
that it has a big depression in it from
just chopping so there's wood getting
into the barbecue too and the key of
whole hog barbecue is you're not eating
the loin or the belly or the shoulder
you're eating all of it cut together and
it's the mix of different cuts some of
them fatty and juicy some of them drier
leaner and the skin as they pronounce it
which is kind of salty and I mean
incredibly captivating ly delicious and
it all gets cut together so there's a
little shards of salt in there with the
meat and and they chop it until it's
fairly fine and they and they mix in
some apple cider vinegar some red pepper
flakes and a little salt and mix it a
little more
and then they put it on a sandwich and
they sell it for two dollars and 75
cents it's a very democratic treat